Here's a picture of the seat heater control in
my car. When I push the control, it prompts
the highest temperature. And then I can push again
to lower the temperature. This design is confusing to
me because this is not in alignment with my
conceptual model of how temperature controls should work. Most
temperature controls I've encountered start with the lowest temperature.
And then move to the highest temperature. I wonder
why the designer designed it this way. What
would your guess be? For the example of
understandable design, here's my iPhone's text messaging feature.
The design is pretty straight forward. The interface guides
me through entering texts into the two required
fields. And then once complete, the Send button
is activated. It's hard to make a mistake
here, in large part because it's easy to discover
what to do, and because of the excellent feedback
provided during interaction. That said, there's usually always room for
improvement in design. How could this design be improved.
And now back to Dawn with examples in the world.